lo cierto es que los tratados europeos
no contemplan ningún procedimiento
extrés de hecho el procedimiento de
adhesión como miembro de la unión
europea es un proceso bastante largo
como comentabas puede ser un proceso del
muy largo de hecho no hay un calendario
fijado a algunos países pueden tardar
más otros pueden tardar menos esta
petición de volodymyr de lenski se
produce a través de tras las palabras
que representa la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen que aseguró que el
lugar de ucrania es la unión europea
pero esto no significa que haya ningún
procedimiento especial para poder entrar
de hecho como comentabas es un proceso
muy largo para poder ser un país
candidato se tienen que negociar 35
capítulos uno por uno se debe cerrar uno
y luego empezar otro eso solo para
convertirse en país candidato luego
empezar las negociaciones de que todas
las leyes se tienen que estandarizar y
regularizar con las de la unión europea
de hecho no es un procedimiento nada
fácil para que se hagan una idea
macedonia del norte por ejemplo empezó a
ser candidato en 2009 pero no fue
candidato oficial hasta 2014 o por
ejemplo turquía que lleva siendo
candidato desde hace 20 años sin embargo
este mensaje que envía hoy de lenski sí
que envíes un mensaje político muy
fuerte que envía su apoyo en que dice
que su apoyo está más cerca de europa
que de rusia